hi there steve kaufman here how is
everybody today i'm going to talk about
error correction
and
how to do it
and
when it's useful and when it isn't
um i'm going to do this in response to a
question i received from one of my
viewers i believe i can't find the
original comment very often because
i
sometimes can't remember whether a
question came via google plus or on the
forum at link or here at youtube
some of the questions fall between the
cracks but one of my viewers said could
i provide some
references for the position that error
correction doesn't help
i did a bit of googling really i think
the viewer i think he was from brazil
you just have to google google error
correction language learning there are
two names that will come up stephen
krashen k-r-a-s-h-e-n
and benico mason
m-a-s-o-n is mason and benico is
b-e-n-i-k-o
and i believe benico mason did some
research with
some groups of students
some of whom had a correction
of their writing and the other group
didn't and it had very little effect
bear in mind that both mason and krashen
are very much proponents of the sort of
lots of reading lots of input free
reading and they very much believe as i
do that massive exposure to input of
this nature
is a better way to spend your time than
worrying about
uh corrections
i think the biggest advantage to
say writing and having it corrected is
the fact that you're right
not so much the correction
but
i would say this about correction based
on my experience my own experience of
being corrected i would say that the
best time to correct someone
is when they are already quite good in
the language
once a number of other things have
started to fall into place once we have
a sense for the language we have words
we've kind of figured out figured out
the structure we've
found our own way to
figuring out how things happen in the
language and yet there's still lots of
gaps
and lots of you know black holes
at that time we may have developed
certain habits
and at that time to have those mistakes
pointed out may work i think the second
condition and maybe i should say that to
me there are two conditions for
correcting people whether it's spoken or
written condition number one it's best
to correct people when they are already
at least intermediate and possibly even
advanced and not before
and second of all that only correct
people who
give you permission to correct them
don't volunteer to correct people
so why we should be not correct
beginners because when you're beginning
there are so many things you have to
learn there are so many things that are
unknown that the number of corrections
that can be made are going to have a
minimal impact on you because you're
struggling with so many different
aspects of the language you won't
remember the correction
it doesn't relate to anything in my
experience i feel that initially with
the language i have to sort of expose
myself self start noticing things
gradually get better at
doing certain things there are certain
aspects of the language for example in
the cases in russian or tenses
and verb endings in romance languages
that you can be corrected but there's no
way you're going to be able to reproduce
them correctly even after having been
corrected you just need that additional
exposure experience and gradually you
will improve and then you may find after
a while that there are certain tenses or
certain verb endings or certain case
cases that give you particular trouble
and at that point it may be worthwhile
to point out
um
a mistake it may or may not have an
impact
um
you know uh but
so some people say well you might
develop bad habits i don't think you
develop bad habits when you first start
out everything is such a mess
you're struggling to understand
struggling to read struggling to speak
you're not going to develop any bad
habits
at a later stage though
you may
certain things may not sort of auto
correct so they then will become bad
habits but at that time
there'll be relatively fewer of them and
therefore to have them pointed out
there's a better chance
that you might be able to remember it
and then incorporate this correct way of
speaking
in your language but i can remember i
mean
talking to people when i'm giving
english uh you know having english
conversations with our learners at link
via skype and i was with a german
gentleman and he kept on saying berlin
you know i live in berlin berlin
and i said now in english actually the
accent is on the second syllable so why
wouldn't you say berlin because even in
german the accent is on the second
syllable oh thank you very much and for
the rest of the conversation he kept on
saying berlin like it didn't change and
he already spoke quite well
uh you know i have a very good swedish
friend and he has the sort of make some
of the typical swedish mistakes of
someone who speaks very well like
instead of saying there are
many swedes in sweden he will say it is
many swedes in sweden because that's how
it's set in swedish and i pointed out he
continues to make the same mistake it's
like the german smith
i i have been living in canada since
many years instead of four many years
some of these things i think if you
point them out at the beginning i don't
think it has any impact
as i say with the chinese who
because in spoken chinese there's no
difference between he and she
they will say you know my husband she
you know my my sister he
uh you can point it out and it may or
may not
i think
part of it is i know that i find that
when things are pointed out to me
uh either i have the feeling that
there's so many things that i'm
struggling to
get a grasp on that has no impact and i
pay no attention
or i know that this is something now
that i'm fairly good that i should be
able to do that and i want to be able to
get that correct you know and say it
correctly so then if i really am
determined to improve and focus on it
and it's not i'm not swamped by all
these other problems in the language
then at that stage
then uh i think the correction uh can be
helpful so
that's my take on it i think in the
beginning you know at at least until the
person is a good intermediate uh you
know the main thing is if they want to
start using the language now to
encourage them to use the language the
more they speak the better they will
notice a lot of the mistakes themselves
they will notice where their problems
are and hopefully start to look for that
in the language when they're reading and
speaking and so don't interrupt them
with every little mistake that they make
and then
later on as they get better and now you
can hone in on a few limited areas where
they need to
try at least to
correct some of their uh
call it bad habits or mistakes
but always with the permission
because the main thing in language
communication is just that communication
so if i'm communicating even poorly and
i want to communicate and it's something
that's important to me that i want to
say and i want to understand what the
other person is saying
and and if someone then starts to
interrupt me with corrections while i'm
speaking then
the communication
is no longer the main objective it's not
been changed from a communication
exercise
to a
to a teaching
you know scenario so if i asked for it
fine but otherwise i prefer just to
communicate which makes us wonder in our
school system why we put so much effort
into correcting the kids there the main
thing is to get them to speak forget the
correction get them to listen read and
speak
and if they actually do develop any kind
of ability to communicate in the
language it's never too late to go in
and make corrections later on i know
there are lots of
learners who think they need to be
corrected they want to be corrected
if they don't get corrected they feel
they're not getting their money's worth
from the class or something i mean
that's all wrong
in my opinion
the the initiative and learning has to
be with a learner
and no one is going to correct you to
fluency no one is going to correct you
sufficiently to
to make a big difference if you aren't
the one seeking out the language looking
for how it's
you know
thoughts are expressed proper phrasing
proper patterns
uh trying to communicate
um some up somewhat aware of what your
problems are if you aren't doing that if
you aren't taking the initiative to do
that yourself no amount of correction is
going to make much difference so i think
the initiative is with with us the
learner to get more of the language in
him or her to speak
with the intention of just wanting to
communicate don't worry about
corrections and at a later stage
probably by then a lot of problems will
have resolved themselves and at that
time
if you ask for it it could be useful
for people to correct you so there you
have it bye for now